ocupar el terreno para ampliar la
diferencia
la estrategia de emanuel macrón está
clara para la campaña entre las dos
vueltas el presidente-candidato retoma
los baños de masas y busca el voto en
las tierras de marín lepén piense en la
francia de abajo de na es una de las
localidades más pobres de francia aquí
la candidata de extrema derecha de
agrupación nacional fue la más votada en
la primera vuelta con el 40% de los
apoyos y emanuel macrón quedó tercero
por detrás del izquierdistas jean-luc
mélenchon el desafío del actual
presidente es matizar sus declaraciones
pasadas
fastidiar a los no vacunados usted lo
dijo lo dije de una forma afectuosa de
acuerdo es afectuoso fastidiar a la
gente si usted lo dice si lo toma como
un insulto si cuando digo estoy
fastidiada es un insulto así si es un
insulto
para calmar las aguas también está
dispuesto a modificar su reforma de las
pensiones
lo que digo es que quiero hacerlo
progresivamente dije que el horizonte
era 2030 pero no hay fetichismo si hay
que establecer un horizonte más corto
para modificar la edad de referencia
puede discutirse la propia parte de sus
discursos por otro lado marín le pen no
cambia sus costumbres en su xi ciudad
devota de su causa intenta encarnar la
candidata defensora del poder
adquisitivo y de la ruralidad como ha
hecho desde el inicio de su campaña por
segundo ufo no se lo quiero devolver a
los franceses su dinero quiero a través
de una serie de medidas no sólo
comprometerme a facilitar la vida de los
más frágiles pienso en los
discapacitados en los que tienen poca
pensión en las familias solas y
monoparentales e igualmente bajar lo que
les quitamos porque les quitamos su más
considerado como pastor un loco de son
que son considerados ya que a la segunda
vuelta al epen plantea distintas visitas
dos meetings y dos días de preparación
para el debate con macro